hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to an
edition of ask Evan today mention a
question from one of my Twitter
followers Rory Armstrong who wrote
insane hi Evan how did you create your
homepage dashboard with social media
channels interesting so thanks for the
question Rory and I thought I said I
create a quick video reply for him so I
think what he's talking about here is if
I go to my homepage here this is what I
this is what I go do every time I load
up my browser so i use chrome but it
works in any any browser that you want
and this is a local file on my computer
that i run when i'm at the office or i'm
at home and it basically lists all the
resources that i use on a daily basis so
i have everything in one quick dashboard
that i can use to run my life and my
business so personal side is just some
investment stuff suppliers paypal my
bank my newsletter business tools that i
used my website this is our backend
stuff some google tools buffer for my
twitter and then things that i look at
on a daily basis these are my facebook
the page custom list that i have on
facebook tweets from hootsuite custom
tools that we've used google google plus
and a couple other things that i checked
on a regular basis and this is
constantly being modified depending on
what i am using and what I'm not using
so i haven't been using these two for a
while so maybe i should remove them
that's yes you do it right now so i'll
show you how i do it now there's two
ways to do it one is more complicated
than the other so the the way that i use
is through dreamweaver to program by
adobe and this is my page and basically
create a series of tables you can put in
pictures if you want or just put in text
and you can add and delete whatever you
want so if i don't actually use these
too much anymore so i can delete those
bring that up and go file save
and then if I go back to my home page
refresh that it's gone so that's it it's
gone and so this is just for you know
four columns and then I add rows if I
need to and I can keep updating it as
much as I want any browser that you have
you can set what your home pages and
most people pick a website but you can
also pick a specific file on your
computer so I just picked the file so
this is how I call it it may not always
be the same depend on your browser is
how chrome does it so file semi colon
slash slash and then the location of
your file so that's my that's that's
where I save it and that's how I do it
through dreamweaver but you can also use
words if you know how to use word you
can also just do that so i'll load up a
word document and all you have to do you
can put pictures and make it fancy as
much as you want but text would do the
job too if you wanted to do what I
didn't have a table you get just go
table put it in for and you can say you
know Twitter and Facebook and email
whatever it is that you want and you can
make those links right just go hyper
link and link off to your HootSuite or
your Twitter or whatever it is that you
want right HTTP you know oops
opportunities in it doesn't matter sure
petrus etsy it doesn't really matter
that becomes a link and then you only
can add as many as you want put in as
many links as you want make it look as
pretty as you want obviously this is
very bare-bones just to show how it's
done then you just save as and one of
the options it'll give you is HTML so
here web page HTML and you can save it
as at HTML document and then that is now
a website and so you don't need to have
dreamweaver fancy no HTML editing
document you can just use you can just
use word to be able to do it for you so
I'd save that as a file and call it
Twitter HTML I could save it as Twitter
or you know
I call mine homepage at attaching a
homepage what is it home page three
because I've got two three versions of
it you call home page whatever you want
and then you save that file to a local
directory and then you just call it when
you go to your browser you call it up
here's then that becomes your default
home page and the load every time you
show up so that's how I do it pretty
simple and hopefully you can use it to
or find it's so much easier to have
everything in one spot that can access
from and just makes my life easier and
reduces the amount of clicks and things
I have to look at so I'm sure we all
spend a lot of time in front of the
computer and as many clicks and needless
navigation you can reduce the better and
so this is what i use and how I do it so
thanks for the crest question Rory for
those of you watching if you enjoyed
please give it a thumbs up below and if
you have a question about this video or
about your business feel free to leave
it in the comments below I always read
those I really loved seeing the comment
it always makes my date is to wake up
and see new comments and likes on the
YouTube video so thank you guys and I'll
see you in the next episode
you
you
you